So the first possibility, or the first choice, is reusing a local
implementation. So let's say that the developer has access to a local
implementation of a class called account. And she then
takes that class account and derives and extends it to, to
create public methods in the API bank account, and creates
a bank account implementation. So she started
with a local implementation of a class account
and extended it to implement the bank account.
Now this bank account service that has been
created, she has to make that visible outside,
in the network, so that any client can
access it. So this is where she uses
the built-in class available in the distributed object
model of Java called the remote Interface.
And what she does is, using that built
in remote class that's available in the distributed
object model of Java, she makes the methods
in the bank account class that she created visible on the network. As a result
of this, so now she's created this interface
derived from the remote interface she has created,
this interface for her bank account object. And so this interface becomes now
publicly available for anyone to access. So clients on the network can have
access to this interface bank account.
Now she instantiates this bank account implementation.
. What happens when the bank
account implementation is actually instantiated? The location
of the bank account implementation object, the instantiation that
she has done, is not visible to the client.
All that is visible to the client is the
interface. The actual location of the object is not something
that is visible to the client, and therefore the
implementer has to do the heavy lifting of finding a
way to make the location of the service visible
to the clients on the network. So in the first
choice, all that we used was the built-in class
and the distributed object model of Java, which is
a remote interface to publish the interface for a
facility that we created. In this case, the bank
account and the methods in it. And once we
publish it, that interface is available. Because we derived
it from the remote interface, the int, the specific
interface, bank account interface, is available for any client
on the network. However, when we instantiate the object, the location of the
object where that service is available is not something that is readily visible
to the client. And so the heavy lifting has to be done by
the implementer to make that object that
had been instantiated visible on the network.